Narrator: From oil paintings
blackened by tobacco smoke
to broken century-old marble statues,
from books ripping apart at the seams
to faded Italian murals,
these items were in
desperate need of repairs.
We spoke with specialists to find out
how they repair and restore
centuries-old works of art.
My name is Sarah Drew, and
I work as an art conservator
at Center Art Studio in New York City.
This is a portrait of Madame Vestris.
The first thing we do
is inspect the painting
with a blacklight to understand
what all the issues are.
So you see the purple light,
and then you see the kinda,
like, the greenish light?
That indicates to us that
there's, like a heavy,
thick old varnish on that surface.
If there wasn't that, you
would just see pure purple.
You couldn't make out any sort of contrast
or light in the background.
The ornament and the
details on her clothes
were completely obscured.
There was something on her head;
we weren't sure if it was
a hat or if it was hair.
When you're running the
Q-tip over the painting,
it can be quite black or quite
orange or yellow depending
on what you're taking off.
Her skin was beautiful.
It was bright, it had brushstrokes,
color contrast, light.
The first step of removing the
painting from the stretcher
is to take out all of the tacks
that are holding the sides of
the canvas onto the stretcher.
I'll save them and I'm
gonna reuse them later.
You can see me using a knife
to separate the lining canvas
fully from the structure.
Now comes the riskiest part,
separating the painting
from the stretcher.
You want to be very careful
because if the paint is not stable,
you risk bending the
painting and causing flaking
or further damage.
I need to cut strips of linen
and attach them to the canvas
so that I can then put the
whole piece back together again.
I cut strips of BEVA, which
is a conservator's adhesive.
I then put the painting on the stretcher
and use tacks to reattach
the painting to its stretcher
Then I filled, with a water
based putty, areas of damage.
And I overfill the areas a little bit,
and then I come back in
with a damp cotton swab
and clean up those fills.
Also, the original canvas
doesn't extend quite to the edges
of the stretcher so I need to go and fill
about a quarter of an inch
around the entire
perimeter of the painting.
Once the painting is filled,
I will begin the retouching process.
I will use a paint that
is specifically designed
for conservation work.
You're just trying to match the color
to the color that the artist put there,
and making sure that
you're not painting over
any of that original paint.
There's two types of
inpainting that I will do here.
The first is inpainting over
the fills that I just made.
The second is inpainting the background.
And this is the area that
was previously overcleaned
by the other restorer.
It's really important to
use a conservation paint
that dissolves in a
solvent that is different
than the original paint.
And this allows our paint
to be completely reversible.
We could easily use that
solvent to take off our paint
and then the original
paint would be unaffected.
Then I will be ready for varnish.
We use a completely reversible
non-yellowing varnish.
I need to wipe off the
surface of the painting
with just a cloth because, like anything,
it can accumulate little
particles of dust, little hairs.
I wanna make sure that that
surface is as clean as possible.
So once I wipe it off, I
will brush on the varnish.
When you brush on the varnish,
those fills, that inpainting,
it all kind of blends
cohesively into the background
and into the surface of the painting
and it just looks complete.
And the restoration is complete.
[soft music]
I'm restoring a portrait of Edmund Holland
that was painted in 1895.
This painting is an oil on canvas,
and it is in a painted
and gilt wood frame.
Both the painting and the
frame are extremely dirty.
The painting has a very
yellow varnish on its surface,
and the frame has many cracks and chips
and loose areas that we will fix.
So, the first thing is to unbox it
when it arrives and to
do an initial assessment,
take note of any condition issues,
and then you start the
deconstruction process.
We're going to work on the painting
and the frame separately.
The painting is held into
the frame with nails,
so I used pliers to bend the nails out,
and it's pretty easy.
There were only a few of them.
I'm going to work on
restoring the painting.
My colleague Caryn is going to
work on restoring the frame.
So, we bring the frame into our wood room
so Caryn can get started working on that.
I begin by taking the
painting off the stretcher.
So, in order to do this,
I remove the tacks along
the sides of the stretcher
that are holding the canvas
tightly onto the stretcher.
I use pliers to pull these tacks out,
and that loosens the painting
and allows it to be a free
piece of canvas again.
When the painting comes off the stretcher,
it's not uncommon for a
painting to not lie flat
because it's been held bent for decades.
So I cut a piece of silicone release paper
and use a small tacking iron
to iron down the edges of
the canvas so it lays flat.
I do an initial vacuum to remove
all the bulky, loose, obvious dust
that is accumulated on
the back of the canvas
and the front of the canvas.
After I vacuum, I use a
vulcanized rubber sponge
to remove more surface dust
and dirt that is a
little bit more ingrained
into the surface of the canvas.
This is a specially made sponge
that is very porous
and pulls dirt off of surfaces
that might be slightly more
ingrained into the surfaces.
We use light pressure with the sponge,
and we tend to go
in straight lines
as opposed to circular
or scrubbing patterns.
We do a surfactant cleaning
to remove grease and
grime and oily substances
off the surface of the painting.
At this point, I'm
still not doing anything
to affect the varnish
or the underlying paint
or anything like that.
We use cotton swabs dipped in a solution
of the surfactant, soap,
and water, typically.
Wet the swab, and then wipe the swab
in typically circular motions
over small areas of the canvas at a time.
And this is a very controlled way
to remove the sticky, grimy substances
that accumulate on a
painting surface over time.
The soap solution also removed overpaint
from a previous restorer.
There are a number of tears in the canvas
that have been repaired by somebody else,
and they were not repaired very well.
So I removed all that off.
[scraping]
Underneath, the previous restorer
had put a layer of paper
on the surface of the painting,
which is an odd thing to do.
So I used a scalpel to scrape that off,
but between the heat gun and the scalpel,
we can scrape off the paper,
and we will repair these areas
by patching them on the back
and using a putty to
fill in just the crack
and make sure that we are not covering
over any of the original paint.
Once I've done my surfactant cleaning,
I am ready to assess the
painting with a black light
and do some solvent tests
to see what will cut through the varnish
and get down to the original paint layer.
I use an ultraviolet black
light to assess the surface.
And this light allows me to see things
that are going on under
the surface of the varnish
that might not be apparent to a naked eye.
I assemble various solvents
that I believe will be
contenders for cleaning.
And I do very small test cleanings
in discrete areas on the canvas
to test and work out a plan
for cleaning the entire
surface of the canvas.
And I check my work with a black light
to make sure that what
I'm doing is working.
If I shine the black light
over my test cleaning,
I want to see that that
test-cleaning window
is reflecting back purple.
That means that I've cut
through that varnish,
I've gotten down to the original paint,
and it informs me and
makes me feel comfortable
moving forward to work in larger areas.
But similar to the surfactant cleaning,
I use large cotton swabs to work my way
over the entire surface of the painting,
and so satisfying to see
all the old yellow varnish come off.
I saved the face for
last in this instance,
mostly because it's the most dramatic part
of the cleaning process,
and so it's good motivation to keep going.
And we want to get to the face,
so that's the most fun part to clean.
It also became apparent once
I removed all the varnish
that this painting,
which had been treated by
this other restorer, had
been cleaned previously.
However, it was cleaned a
little too aggressively.
So there were areas where
the original paint had become thin.
So, now I'm realizing that I have
maybe a lot more retouching in my future
than I maybe anticipated.
Once the painting is clean,
we remove the old patches
and the old strip-lining canvas
that's on the back of the painting.
Lansing, who is the owner of the studio,
is doing this part.
Lansing is taking off the old
patches and the old strips.
To do this, he uses a hot-air gun
to heat up the patches,
and this loosens up the older pieces
and allows Lansing to take a metal tool
to lift off the patch.
And we're left with the original canvas.
We will strip line the
edges of the canvas.
This is so we will be able to
restretch the painting
tightly onto the stretcher.
We cut strips of linen
and adhere conservator's
adhesive to the strips,
and this is heat activated.
So we use an iron to attach these strips
to the back of the original canvas.
We also will do the same technique
for the patches that are on the back,
and these patches will repair
the rips that are in the canvas' surface.
We glue down the frayed
edges of the strip lining
so they also lay flat
against the original canvas.
Lansing will restretch the painting
onto its original structure.
He marks the middle of all
four sides of the painting
and all four sides of the stretcher,
and then he lays the loose
canvas onto the stretcher,
aligns the marks, and then
begins the stretching process.
He will use a tacking hammer
and the original tacks
that I removed earlier that we saved
to reattach the canvas to the stretcher.
Now my colleague Tyler will be applying
a layer of isolation varnish
to the painting surface
to protect all the original paint
and create a barrier
between the original paint
and the paint and materials
that I'm going to apply.
We're using a reversible,
nonyellowing conservator's varnish
that's easily removable.
We brush it onto the
painting surface all over
and allow it to dry.
At this point, we put the keys
in the back of the stretcher
and tap the keys to make
the surface of the painting
completely taut on the stretcher.
[tapping]
Once the canvas is taut,
we use a water-based putty
to fill the cracks in the canvas' surface
and fill in any areas along the edges
or wherever it might need to
have a surface evened out.
I select the colors that I expect
I will need for retouching.
We're using Gamblin conservation paints.
These are paints that
are specifically designed
for conservation work, and they're soluble
in solvents that are
different than solvents
that will affect the oil paint.
So, again, it's always very easy to remove
for whatever reason.
I mix the colors to try to match
the original color as best as possible.
I'll put paint on the surface;
if it looks correct, I'll continue.
If I need to alter it, I will.
One of the issues with this
painting was that it has been
previously overcleaned
by another restorer.
To fix all this, I will
remove the previous restorer's paint
and inpaint in just those areas of loss,
where it's been, with our
own conservation paint,
stippling very carefully in
very, very, very small areas
to make the painting look complete again.
I'm very careful to only
put this conservation paint
in the areas of loss.
I never want to cover
up any original paint
or do anything to obstruct
the original materials
the artist put there.
I inpaint the entirety of the canvas,
and we do a final coat of varnish again.
This final coat, it's the moment of truth.
It brings out all the work,
and once the final layer of
varnish is on and it dries,
the painting restoration is complete.
Now there's the whole
frame restoration. [laughs]
Caryn does an allover vacuuming
and then a sponge treatment
of the frame surface
to remove any loose dust.
Now we clean the frame.
We use the same surfactant soap
that we use on the painting surface.
Two of the four mitered
corners on the frame
have very large gaps.
So we first will use a epoxy putty
to fill these areas,
and then come in and fill over that
with a water-based putty.
We fill the large ones.
It's always a judgment call,
but we leave the smaller ones
to retain an element of age.
The ornament detail on two
corners of the frame are missing.
We need to make a mold of
the ornament that does exist.
Then we use a plaster to
actually cast a replacement.
Caryn glues them down onto the frame,
does a little bit more shaping,
and then we're ready to retouch the frame.
[machine whirring]
Once we have the frame retouched,
we apply shellac to protect our work
and make sure it's all sealed.
Now the painting and the frame
restorations are complete.
We put the painting into the frame,
and we hang the painting up on the wall,
and admire our work. [laughs]
My team and I are going
to walk you through
step by step how we restore
a 250-plus-year-old
French plaster and giltwood frame.
This frame was brought
to us by a private client
along with a painting that
we will restore as well.
The frame, when it came to us,
was extremely dirty,
and it needed a lot of structural repairs.
There was a lot of
ornament that was missing.
When we start cleaning the frame,
we start with the back.
There's a lot of resin
on the back of the frame,
so we use a scalpel to
scrape this resin off.
It's likely some sort of polyurethane
from a previous restoration.
That stuff is tricky to remove,
so mechanically removing it with a scalpel
is the best approach.
Once we have the back clean,
we flip the frame right side up
and we start the front cleaning.
We commonly use cotton swabs
to clean the surface of a frame,
but we also are going to
be using micro-metal tools,
literally the same tools
that a dentist will use
to really get into all of
the small little recesses.
We use a variety of solvents,
which lift the dirt up
and allow us to then take swabs
to lift the dirt away.
This frame was originally water gilded,
which means gold leaf was applied to it.
Because of that, we have to be
very careful with our cleaning,
because it would be very easy
to remove that original gilding.
We never want to make
something look brand new.
So while we are going into the recesses
and we are removing the dirt,
we don't want to entirely remove
all of that built-up patina.
We want to retain an element of age.
The main issue with the back of this frame
is that it has been expanded
to take a larger piece of art
than it was originally built for.
The first time we saw it,
we knew that we were going
to have to disassemble it
and build it back up properly.
In order to put the frame back properly,
we are using a product called fish glue,
which is a super-condensed fish product.
It's a very traditional adhesive
to use in conservation,
and it's very strong.
And then we align the frame.
Once we feel that all the structural work
has been completed,
we move on to filling in
the missing areas of the frame.
Three of the four corners
are completely missing
their corner ornament.
Luckily, we have one corner
that is completely intact.
That works to our advantage in this case,
because we will be able
to take a silicone mold of this corner
and then cast plaster replicas of it.
To make a mold off the frame,
we use a silicone compound.
Once you have it mixed together,
you can lay it over a part of the frame
that you want to replicate.
It cures over the course of about
20 or 30 minutes.
Once it's fully cured,
you can carefully peel it off the frame,
and you will have the imprint
of the shape of the frame
that you want to replicate in that mold.
We are using plaster to cast the molds.
So we mix up a batch of plaster,
and we pour it into the silicone mold.
Once the plaster has dried,
we can pop that out of the mold.
To prepare the frame to
receive the plaster casts,
we need to remove some
of the plaster material
that's already on it.
We use a hammer and chisel
to carve away a recess that will allow
the cast piece to sit flush in the frame.
We will shape and
finesse these cast pieces
to make sure that they fit properly
in the areas where we're
going to be applying them.
We use sandpaper in different grits.
We are using fish glue again
to adhere the cast pieces onto the frame.
When we feel like the frame
is physically complete,
it is time to move on to the color work.
The first layer of paint
that we are applying to
the frame is a primer.
This is a Venetian red primer.
And that just creates a
very nice red base layer
for us to work off of.
We are gold-leafing the ornaments
in the corners of this frame.
This is a process called gilding.
The frame was originally
gilded with gold leaf.
And so whenever possible,
we like to use the original
materials in our restoration,
just so the object has as much integrity
to the original as possible.
The first step to gilding
after you've applied the base layer
is to apply a sizing medium.
And this is brushed onto the plaster,
and it is allowed to dry
for about 30 minutes.
It gets tacky.
And once it's tacky,
it's in the right state
to accept the gold leaf.
It is very, very delicate,
so you can't touch it with your hands.
It will just crumble.
So in order to handle it,
Caryn, one of our team members,
is using a horsehair brush
and lay it onto the ornament
that we want to gild.
We also will use squirrel-hair brushes
to brush it on and make
sure that it's adhering
to all of the recesses and
all of the areas of the frame.
Once the gold leaf is applied,
we move on to the inpainting process.
And we are going to
paint over the gold leaf
to tone it down slightly,
and also over all of the fills
that we've made on the frame.
And we use a combination
of conservation colors,
which are paints
that are specifically designed
for conservation work.
It is literally a trial-and-error process.
Often, we will make a color,
we'll have to adjust it,
correct it a little bit.
This is where the frame
starts to really look
like one whole object again.
The next step is to
apply a layer of shellac.
And this just serves as a topcoat.
It protects all of our work.
It also makes everything
just have a cohesive finish and sheen.
We're really happy with how
this restoration came out.
We have done a lot
to restore the structural integrity
and the visual integrity of this frame,
and we hope the client can enjoy the frame
for years to come.
[angelic orchestral music]
I am going to walk you
through how my team and I
restore a 19th-century
Italian marble sculpture
and its alabaster base.
So it's been broken,
it's been previously repaired.
It came to us broken again.
This work of art is comprised
of four separate pieces.
That includes the marble bust,
its socle base, and a pedestal,
which is in two parts, a top and a column.
We're going to clean the
bust, the socle base,
and the pedestal
components all separately.
We start out on all of the pieces
by using a surfactant detergent
diluted in distilled water
and spray it onto the
marble and the alabaster.
We want to use what we need
to properly clean a piece,
but we never want to do anything
that's too harsh.
And this surfactant is very gentle,
and it lifts the dirt off the surface,
kind of breaks the surface tension
between the dirt and the surface,
and allows us to wipe or swab away
the accumulated surface dirt and debris.
The column is quite dirty,
and this is because a pedestal column
sits on the floor
and the dirt from the
floor, from people's shoes,
it all gets brought up onto that surface.
We also use surfactant gels,
particularly in areas that might be
a little bit more stubborn to clean.
When restoring something so old,
you have to be mindful
of the age of the piece.
So we never want to remove all of the dirt
out of all of the recesses
and completely remove the patina
that's built up on an item of age
because that would end up
looking incorrect and inappropriate.
So the top of the pedestal
and the socle base
that the bust sits directly on
have both been previously repaired twice
with the same types of glue.
We need to entirely remove
all of this old adhesive
that's not functional, it's yellowing,
it's not good for the marble
to have on its surface.
So we want to make sure
we get all of it off.
So we are using a combination of scalpels.
This is also a time
where you have to be very careful
because marble is very susceptible
and alabaster is very, very susceptible
to scratching.
So when you're using
those very sharp tools
you want to make sure
that you are only scraping off the glue
and you're not accidentally nicking
the surrounding surface area.
We use a number of visual aids to help us
in the conservation process.
One tool that's very helpful
is a small spotlight.
This is a very direct, targeted light
that allows us to very
clearly see the area
that we are working on.
We also use a black light,
which is very useful
because the UV light
allows us to see imperfections
and residues on the surface
that are not visible to
the regular human eye.
To attach the broken items back together,
we are going to use a
special conservation epoxy.
It is called Epo-Tek.
This is a two-part epoxy
that you combine together.
When you first mix it,
it can be quite liquidy,
so we allow it to sit
for a little bit of time
just to develop little bit more
of a viscous quality.
We are going to permanently
attach the marble
to the socle base.
We're going to reuse
the original metal rod.
Once we have it at the right depth,
we put the pin in the hole of the bust
and we use our epoxy,
pour that into the recess.
And then we put the base on the marble,
check it for alignment,
front to back and left to right,
and allow that to cure for a little while.
To ensure that the repair
of the top of the pedestal
is extremely strong,
we are going to pin the pieces
in addition to epoxying them.
We are going to take
a stainless-steel rod.
Stainless steel is desirable
because it's not going to rust
or change over time.
We mark on the outside of the piece
where we're going to drill holes
to take the pins.
And we are using our ancient drill press.
Once we have the holes, we have the pins,
we then can use our epoxy
to attach the two pieces back together.
We are going to fill the cracks
in the sculpture with plaster.
We are applying the plaster
with small metal tools.
We tend to err on the side of overfilling
because it's very easy
to remove the plaster material.
The plaster cures quickly, so you want
to make sure that you're getting enough on
while it's still workable.
Once we've filled the cracks
and we've allowed the
plaster to fully dry,
we are going to sand,
particularly the alabaster base,
which had a large crack
throughout the entire thing.
We are going to sand that down
with different grits of sandpaper.
In painting, a marble sculpture
is really the same technique that we use
for any other sculpture or a painting.
We are using our standard
Gamblin Conservation Colors.
We mix them up to get the right color.
In this instance,
because the marble and the alabaster
are sort of translucent,
it makes our job a little trickier
because we're trying to
replicate translucency
on an opaque fill.
In this instance, you
really can't mix one color
and apply it to the whole fill.
You have to do thin
washes of different colors
to mimic the texture and the veining
of the stone material.
We are going to polish the alabaster base,
and we use a very large
polishing wheel for this.
And we use polishing compound
applied to the wheel,
and that polishing compound comes
in a variety of grits.
We use very fine ones in this instance
so it doesn't damage the alabaster.
The final step of the conservation
is to wax each piece of the sculpture.
So we are using
a very, very fine microcrystalline wax.
And we apply this
over the whole surface of
each one of the pieces,
allow it to dry for just a little bit,
and then buff it off very gently
with soft cloths.
This wax is important.
It not only makes the
stone look good visually,
it also serves as a protective layer
between the stone and the elements.
Once all of the components
are complete in their own right,
we do a final assembly, and this is how
the piece will be ultimately displayed
at the client's home.
We are very satisfied
with how the whole piece came out.
We know the client loves this piece
and has had it broken for a long time.
We think she's going be very happy.
[bright, jaunty music]
[soft music]
[light scraping]
[water pouring]
My name is Sophia Bogle.
I've been restoring
books for over 25 years,
and I started my company, Save Your Books,
so that anyone can learn
archival-book repair.
The book I'm restoring today is
the Hans Christian
Andersen "Fairy Tales" book
from the late 1800s, early 1900s.
[soft music]
The first thing that we do
in pretty much any full restoration
is we have to separate the cover
from the text block.
The tool that I prefer to use
is the book-repair knife.
It has a rounded tip
and is less likely to do
damage that you did not intend
as an X-Acto knife would.
I'm removing the old tape.
It's very acidic,
and if I leave it on the book at all,
it's going to affect the book later on.
When you're removing some
of the original material
and you know you're going to be
replacing it with something,
it's good to mark where it was
in relationship to the other materials.
And so in this case,
I've used a pencil and a piece of paper
to mark where the original went.
I'm using a 100-grit sanding block
to clean the edges of these boards off.
It makes a nice, clean edge.
[soft music]
[light scraping]
A lot of general cleaning can be done
using a book-repair knife,
and using the book-repair knife
to just remove some clumpy bits
that are stuck to the end paper.
[water pouring]
When you're repairing a book,
usually all the pages are still connected,
and there are some pages that will benefit
from this washing technique that I have.
It'll help us to get the
tape off of the page,
in a way that you couldn't do
if it was attached to the book still.
To wash a page,
to get rid of the tape,
you just have to put
it in fairly hot water.
You aren't going to need any
additives to clean these pages.
It's just hot water.
It's surprisingly effective.
It can sit in the water for hours.
You're also just going to have to be
very delicate with the paper,
because it's in a more delicate state
when it's in the water.
I'm using a microspatula
to help separate the pages,
and I'm also using a ruler
to help hold down the other page.
You can use a soft brush
to help you to brush
away the old adhesive.
[soft music]
When you're touching up
anything black on a cover,
you're going to want
to use an archival pen.
It's a 0.08-micron pen,
and it is archival ink.
The smaller the tip, the better, in a way.
Do not use a Sharpie.
Those will damage and discolor.
[soft music]
While I was cleaning,
I also noticed that some
of the gilt stamping
has been removed.
When I'm using the word "gilt,"
gilt refers to gold.
So it's gold stamping on the cover.
Some people would call it embossing.
Originally, this was stamped
with hot metal plates,
with foil coming down onto the book.
The best way to fill in gilt stamping
is to use shell gold.
I'm using a liner brush,
and I have all the control in the world.
You're going to make mistakes.
You can actually remove the gilt
by using a cuticle stick,
and then you can clean up your gilt.
[soft music]
If you want to match
the color of your book
and do touch-up on the covers,
it's not as hard as you might think.
You look at this, this
is a greenish brown.
The brownish colors that tend
to be on these older books,
they're muddy looking.
And the way to get to
that muddy-looking color
is to go across the color wheel
from the color you think it is
and add that other color to
make it more muddy looking.
[soft music]
When you find tears on your pages
and you want to repair them,
I highly recommend using
Japanese tissue that's thin
and an archival paste,
such as what I have here,
which is nori paste.
It's a rice-starch paste.
A really thin tissue is going to be better
than a thicker tissue.
You don't need very much paste.
[soft music]
You get everything ready.
You've got your book in the cover,
right side up.
You're going to be gluing
all of those materials.
You're going to glue that
mull and that little hinge,
and you're gluing that
decorative end sheet back,
and then you're going to close the cover.
[soft music]
And then you slip a sheet of wax paper in.
And then you put the pressing board in.
When I discovered that there were
pages missing from this book,
I found a version of
the story that connected
to where the book started
with the pages missing.
I used paper that's
called antique endleaf.
[soft music]
I am using a colored
pencil to color the edges
of the new pages that I added to the book.
I don't want them to pop out.
I don't want it to look obvious
that I added these new pages.
[soft music]
And that's it.
That's our book.
[soft music]
My name is Andrea Sozzi Sabatini,
and I'm the CEO and founder of Etrurio.
It's a farm where it aims to produce
top-quality olive oil in Tuscany.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how Marco restores this beautiful
583-year-old fresco.
The first work that we have to do
is to consolidate the walls.
The first thing is
really to take the stones
that are unstable, take them off,
consolidate whatever is underneath,
and then put the stones
back to their places.
In this large fresco, there
are cracks here and there,
so the next step is to
consolidate these cracks.
The cracks get consolidated
with resin, special resin.
The next step is now
to remove the plasters
that had been painted over the fresco
in the last few centuries.
And to do that, Marco, the restorer,
needs to get archeological scalpel
and remove every single bit and pieces
out of this huge surface.
And it's very delicate work,
because if you are not precise enough
of course you can damage
the fresco itself.
Now that the plaster has been removed,
we can apply Japanese paper
soaked with water and ammonium carbonate.
This is a very delicate process.
And the reason why we
are doing it is because,
thanks to the Japanese paper,
all the dirt and all
the external component
get away from the fresco.
And it's a process that
can last up to six months.
After all this work, as you can see,
the fresco is revealing itself.
Some of the colors are now vivid.
What was underneath the plaster
fortunately is still there for most of it.
We are actually applying
again Japanese paper
soaked with a different
product, carbonate hydroxide.
And this is a very important
part of the fresco restoration,
because it stabilize the fresco itself.
Now that all these
processes are completed,
Marco can start the second
phase of the restoration.
As you can see,
there's a lot of gaps in the fresco,
because some of the paint has faded,
some others were lost.
He's going to use a
very tiny, small brush,
and he is going to use a natural pigment,
like they were used back in the 1400s.
There has been a surveillance
of the Italian authority over this fresco.
We are not allowed in Italy
to paint back anything
that is not present.
The whole restoration took a long time.
It took 18 months.
We are very proud that
we didn't lose this
piece of art in Tuscany.